you should Keane Griffin the former
Central Florida linebacker the star of
the combine who joins us on the program
heard you missed your flight
earlier this morning what happened yeah
I mean doing just doing the second floor
that's when I started cramping up really
bad and you know I did I made sure I had
to finish the drills and stuff and I was
coming through all the drills and by the
time I got ready for my flight I
couldn't I cut my move Oh see you I had
to go get ya so physically walk oh boy
no yeah so I had to go get Joe I
wouldn't go get treatment and gotta get
hydrated again and took me a minute so
weary booked my flight for the morning
how do you feel today so much better my
calf muscles was tired and I was and I
know during the drills is like you know
you can slow down it's okay laughter I
was like no I don't believe in that so I
made sure I didn't drills cramping
enough how bad you know yeah I felt I
felt that after that how fast could you
run the 40 today uh wrestling fast not
slowing down
I still I still ran a decent time with
the cramps that second forty you're four
or five yeah it's funny my brother's
like I don't know why I even ran the
second when views already crapper I said
I bet there's so many people who come
and tell I was cramping how surprised
were you your results at the combine I
wasn't surprised at all cuz it feels I I
know what I can do I was ready to show
everybody
but our reaction it feels like I mean
you're getting national exposure how's
this attention feel I mean it's amazing
I mean it shows someone has so much
support that I'm getting from from
everything I mean you can't ask more
than that and I had to support my flags
and I hear even from the point where I
was getting ready for the Senior Bowl
and had everybody
you know even though I wasn't invited at
first a support then and then 19
fighters to the combine had even more
support an entire country behind me got
the got a chance to get the invite I had
opportunity to be here to show everybody
what I ask and do and still even got
some more support after that hour
I mean even when I got to the bench
press I mean the crowd was amazing like
I heard the crowd yelling I felt like I
thought I was Superman up there I mean
literally I just I just I can feel the
crowds like I was like the crowds
helping me live and well you have
support like that I mean it's only gonna
make you do good I mean is your
confidence gonna be able you gonna feel
good about yourself you're gonna feel
strong it just make you just feel good I
mean and then have everybody still
support me and everybody showing love I
mean you can't do nothing but but enjoy
that how should we look at this your
one-handed everybody I mean this has
been known its showcase should we do you
want us to ignore it and just treat you
as a football player or should we
embrace it because of what it means and
what it main means for other people
being inspirational I mean just say for
it for everybody I mean no one wants to
be considered just the player with one
hand but just a football player of
somebody else at one hand a basketball
player they just wanna be considered as
a player not the person with one hand
because you know the reason why I do
what I do now is because I want to get
away from people saying oh he's so good
because he has one hand no I'm good
because I know how to play the game of
football I do everything I work hard you
know I study film I do everything that
it takes for me to be a good player not
because I have one hand and that's what
that's what I do what I do because I
want to be able to say the example for
not only me and people and my family but
people around me who's outside looking
then because I want them to know like
never let nobody tell you that you know
you can do this and you do something
good because you got one no because you
do it because you work hard you deserve
it and and you really a good player and
that's why I want to be able to change
not because people look at people who
look at me one hand was like wow how can
you do this and that's like me saying
you got two hands while how can you do
that you know I want to get away from
from that and say you know what he's a
good player no matter if he got one hand
or 30 hands do you remember when your
left hand was amputated
what were you four yeah I was four
do you remember anything about that day
yes I remember I remember everything to
be honest that's how they put the office
I don't remember that part disaster
remember uh no I was sleeping and I
rolled over hit my hand on the wall
started crying I ran to the kitchen and
it was climbing on top of the sink big
they go to the draw to get a knife out
to cut my fingers off and my mom grabbed
me and she my brother my mom sent my
brother to took my dad room and you know
you know he went to sleep what about the
sleep and my mom brought me back to
sleep and then the next morning I
remember going to the to Bayfront
Hospital and I was dragging a red wagon
and it was nothing in it
I was just dragging around thinking it
was normally there not knowing while I
was there actually because she's dodging
she didn't tell me I was know cuz that's
my mom worried that she were that big
for the hospital and I was dragging my
red wagon I remember she picked me up
and took me into the into the room I was
removal they put a mask on my face and
after that I woke up with bandages is
there anything you can't do on the
football field no limitations I mean I
only let only limits will people say but
you know I put that wrong every single
time I never said limits on things I can
do what was it like when you were
learning to catch the football growing
up oh it was a journey I can tell you
that I took football to the hair before
I actually start catching it you know
that never stopped me from learning I
think as a mom my dad was always no
tough on me about if I want to be able
to do something I gotta be able to be
the best at it and you know harp doing
that and from setting bricks in the
backyard which sticks over to make him
look like hurdles will jump over those
and - throw the ball full speed and I
have to catch it no boy and is but I
learned quick I remember one time he
pulled and they ran the chest I caught
it and I roll all the way to the gate
but I was gonna let that ball go for
over the top now - had ten push-ups I
don't think you want to keep doing ten
pushes over and over again wait if you
drop the ball dad made you do push-ups
yep have you met Jim Abbott
how about met Jim happen that would be
kind of cool I'm a my teacher talking
about Jim happy when I was in a third
grade actually second grade it was
taking it second grade going to third
grade was I was at day care and we're
throwing the ball and
I cannot I cannot keep the ball in my
hand and throw and I can I keep them in
my hand and try to throw the ball is
like a be used to catch the ball
hold the mitt take the take the ball of
the mitt and then to her but it was it
was just so much for me that you can
even tell and trust my I try to do it
I'm not going to hold me it was balling
I guess it took a little more time for
me to learn the former I and Jim Abbott
was a major league pitcher and you know
Chuck came is talking about how he would
get the ball back to him kind of tuck
his glove I mean it was pretty amazing
there was a rhythm to it I would love to
set up a conversation with you and Jim
Abbott if you'd be okay with that he
he's he's a great guy and very giving
and and I'd love for him to get in touch
with you if you're interested in amazing
yeah I'll be amazing where will you be
on draft day after he's still trying to
trying to figure it out but most likely
I'll you know I'm probably be with the
family my brother did it last year you
know we're gonna set something up nice
you know just be around my family you
know we going training and you're gonna
be traveling and taking visitors you
know anything you wanna do is be around
your family before you gotta you gotta
fly out anywhere you know so that's
that's the part of the plan what we
gonna do for now unless I get invited
the data that's another store whoo well
do you have a favorite team uh I mean
growing up my 13 was the Ravens but you
know I was I was a big very Lewis fan I
mean I don't want goodness I used to go
crazy for Ray Lewis so rather than a no
that used to be the days of you to go to
well it was a lot of fun to watch you
play at Central Florida and it was a
great year and certainly with with Scott
frost there and pretty magical to go
undefeated and then finally get invited
to the combine so I hope you feel proud
because you should it's just a football
player but then add everything else
you've overcome sure came and that's
that's pretty incredible
credible journey that's only continuing
yeah good to be a national champion and
still make history wait wait
you're the national champ sir oh yeah
and I'm and I'm helping to create her
own ring suzhou and that's a good
oh you're getting championship rings oh
yeah national something I like ring
don't you wish you could have played
Alabama I mean I would have been amazing
I mean everybody I got UCF like Noah dig
build stinger Alabama but you know we
farfel farfel small we fought and we far
from did not be incapable of playing a
beat school I mean I think we did it
before and the way we came out on top I
mean I don't remember seeing any Arizona
no schedule I mean I look all the time
and you know I don't wear glasses but I
tried dresses on one time and I said I'm
fine al so well there's a lot of del be
used by your name and congrats so far
and hopefully you you get great results
on on with the a draft weekend I'm
looking forward to her thanks for
joining us thank you thank you for
having me
Shiki Griffin nice little sense of humor
there and making up championship rings
Central Florida put on glasses I
couldn't find anything else on that
schedule there but you know it's a great
story and it's not he doesn't want you
to feel sorry for him and he's just used
to this this is the way he's grown up I
was fascinated by him catching the ball
now they had defensive drills where you
go back in coverage and then they throw
you the ball at the combine and you know
he puts his right hand out almost as if
to absorb it and then he cradles it
after that and then you're wondering you
know even making tackles you know making
one arm tackles and pretty fascinated
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you